ja der wille zum ging was habe ich heute
vorher ich habe so die theorie die ich
in gruppen und institutionen entwickelt
habe auf bands anzuwenden und was werde
ich dazu tun ich werde zunächst einige
wahre geschichten über vans in
erinnerung rufen ich werde dann einige
kriterien für theorien über bands
zusammentragen und ich denke dass jede
ware theorie über wenn es diese serien
erfüllen sollte dann durch einige
theorien vorständen die nicht
funktionieren und dann in zwei schritten
meine eigene theorien zunächst werde ich
die uhr als objekt theorie von marke
gilbert fans anbinden und dann in einem
zweiten schritt wenn salz komplexe
institutionelle gebilde zu analysieren
eine erste wahre geschichte die beatles
die beatles ihr als ganze
[Musik]
situation gerade in den anfangsjahren
gab es ein kommen und gehen bis dann
ringo starr dazu kam und dann die große
große stabilität bis 1969 wurde schon
nennen dann unter den schlechten
einfluss von yoko ono die beatles
verließ ihn zwischendurch gab sein ein
tolle musiker
die nicht nicht weiter bekannt in der
popgeschichte
aber
ja man könnte auf den verdacht kommen
dass die drei ländern mccartney harrison
mw den kern
ausmachen werde zwar überall
jänner sind könnten die bietet sein aber
nein nein wenn wir uns anschauen in
welchen bands
sonst noch mitgespielt haben die fing
ich an als schüler in den black jacks
gründeten dann die kva riman
verließen sie spielten in johnny und
termindrucks in japan
sie träumen und erst dann gründeten sie
die beatles also nicht überall wo lennon
mccartney und harrison sind
sie bietet
bei andere geschichte die ac dc tour
2020 ja wohl mal kommen wir nicht mehr
kommt seiner fortgeschrittenen demenz er
blieb
sein bruder erst spielte mit aber
erschien sein früheren elan verloren zu
haben der schlagzeuger für roboter
hausarrest weil einen auftragsmörder
engagiert haben soll und der sänger
brian johnson musste die tour abbrechen
und wurde ersetzt durch axel roos von
guns n roses ja max fellmann der in der
süddeutschen über die tour berichtet
erinnert das ganze an den schwarzen
ritter von
monty python der ohne arme weitergehen
ohne beine und ist das noch eine easy dc
tour können wir fragen
und eine dritte wahre geschichte rs mit
ja der rs mit schlagzeuger drama
verklagt die band um mit
doch nur spielen titelte die faz in
diesem kontext kann denn das sein jack
an den einschlag nicht
ja wenn wir uns diese beispiele angucken
wenn ich außer ein
schmunzeln und staunen jahres
philosophie empfängt er mit dem stern an
wie man sagt ja können wir sagen wenn es
scheinen aus mehreren personen zu
bestehen sie werden zu bestimmten zeiten
gegründet und sie machen musik das sind
schon mal drei kriterien denke ich denn
jede theorie bands gerecht werden soll
dann beim musizieren weisen
wenn es auf die schweiz heilung auf
einer verschiedene
instrument 1000 personen verteilt
wenn es können durch die zehen
existieren und ja möglicherweise sogar
nicht wie die beatles und cdc zeigen zu
verschiedenen
das team bestehen möglich sie können
wenn es auch lücken in ihrer existenz
haben ja denken wir an die blues
brothers
band together again
ja also vielleicht können bands auch
auferstehen
von den toten aber auf jeden fall können
sie aufhören zu existieren wie 1970 die
beatles
ja theorie ja nicht lachen die wir
tatsächlich vorgeschlagen für soziale
gruppen mit wenn wir viele elemente
haben da haben wir doch eine menge sind
bei
sie bietet jünger aus john bull ring
also 1960 bis 62 bestanden sehr aus ganz
anderen elementen also diese mengen
theorie der bands die können wir da auf
jeden fall verbergen wir müssen etwas
raffinierter werden bei und wir könnten
sagen ja
um dem phänomen gerecht zu werden dass
wenn es ihre mitglieder wechseln
austauschen können
müssen wir sagen bands sind nicht mengen
von mitgliedern sondern mengen von
kuppeln von paaren von mengen von
mitgliedern und zeiträume als die
beatles vielleicht
das paar aus der menge john paul
george und pc und andere nicht mal 1960
bis 62 und das paar aus der menge john
paul george und ringo fund 62 69 und so
weiter aber
nicht was wäre wenn es die beatles nie
verlassen hätte nicht
ja nicht der welt und in der besten
aller möglichen welten spielen john paul
george und ringo vielleicht heute noch
zusammen also
[Musik]
die erlassen und lehre nicht erschossen
worden und so weiter ja also von der
raffinierten bei der verbesserten zu
raffinierten theorie
dann wären bands vielleicht ja kribbeln
also komplexe gebilde aus möglichen
welten und mengen
in zwei räumen
im theoretischen strukturen gibt es
natürlich wie sand am meer
warum sollte grad die eine die
struktur bands seien unter einer anderen
nicht nicht also
was wir sagen können für jede band
gibt's eines welchem endgerät struktur
aber
das heißt nicht dass die bands diese
mengen theoretische strukturen sind wir
können nur die mitglieder haben
modellieren mit diesen mengen bands sind
natürlich keine mengen mengen sind
abstrakte entitäten und mengen wenn sind
ja entitäten in raum und zeit sie sind
kausal verantwortlich für jede menge
spannende phänomene die da
entstehen und deswegen keine mengen
ja es
wird oft unterschieden zwischen feature
groups und organize groups which macht
das etwa nicht sind bands feature kurz
sind es gruppen die durch bestimmte
features
zusammengehalten werden durch
eigenschaften die die mitglieder teilen
ja nicht also alle alle bandmitglieder
sind
musiker in der regel in der jedenfalls
nicht ständig gibt es einige bands die
auch
fenster haben das ist nicht da aus
das ist ein typisches feature aber
natürlich gibt es sind nicht alle
musiker
mitglied der gleichen bands nicht da
muss etwas dazukommen wir unterscheiden
stilmäßig auch so was wie schwarze
versus meisters
da spielt dann sowas wie die hautfarbe
natürlich eine rolle aber auch da wieder
das ist nicht sein genug um tatsächlich
die verschiedenen gruppen voneinander zu
unterscheiden das ist eine grobe
unterscheidung von verschiedenen
musikstilen nichts was jetzt konstitutiv
ja gleich oder
also hier gleiche kleidung oder nahe
zueinander passende kleidung ja
das ist
immerhin
zu ein marken
die pilz war nicht bei den frühen
beatles aber viele hatten pilzköpfe
nicht gerade weil die bietet
das ist nicht hinreichend dafür ein
mitglied der beatles zu sein und wie wir
wissen im schwange der
individualisierung in den
späten jahren
traten die bietet dann auch mit
individuelleren äußeren auf das ist also
auch kein hinreichendes kriterium um
eine band zu sein ja wenn es sollten
sich im musikstil einig sein sollte man
meinen
zum irgendwas in einen auftritt haben
sollten sie zur gleichen zeit nicht
unterschiedliche musizieren aber
natürlich kann sich der stil entwickeln
wenn der immer gleich bliebe wäre das ja
auch schrecklich langweilig also ja
natürlich ein auftritt für ein lied mit
müssen sich die mitglieder der bands
irgendwie einigen auf einen stil
aber eines konzertes
könnten die musikszene hätte sich ändern
also alt all das scheint nicht zu
reichen also bands scheinen keine
feature groups zu sein wie wehrt man den
ein bandmitglied
also im bereich der theorien die nicht
funktionieren ja man wird also kein
bandmitglied durch selbst zu schreiben
ja das ist nicht notwendig so kramer
sieht sich natürlich als bandmitglied
darf aber trotzdem nicht mitspielen doch
noch ist es hinreichend nicht also das
zeigt das beispiel von
merkel
außerdem die zuschreibung ist viel zu
ekelig ich könnte mich auch beliebigen
bands zuschreiben würde damit aber
vermutlich eher zum psychiater als in
die parade kommen ja vielleicht ist es
notwendig dass die anderen mitglieder
der bands die
mitglieder anerkennen als mitglieder
da auch das ist weder notwendig noch in
reichen möchte können uns irgendwelche
band projekte vorstellen wo mich die
mitglieder sich regelmäßig treffen haben
sie wissen gar nicht genau mit wem sie
sich da treffen ja vielleicht weil sie
dann alle ausgetragen was weiß ich die
ku klux klan band die sich kennenlernen
auf so einem meeting und sich dort
verabreden aber ja gar nicht ganz wissen
wer da unter der kapuze steckt ja noch
ist es hinreichend denn die mitglieder
könnten sich irren er sie könnten
irgendjemand als bandmitglied anerkennen
der ist aber gar nicht ist sondern der
eineiige zwillinge von dieser person
also aufgrund solcher phänomene reicht
also anerkennung auch nicht außerdem
hätten wir das problem des ersten
mitglieds nein wenn es doch keine
mitglieder gibt wie wer soll dann die
anderen als mitglied anerkennen
wir müssen vielleicht benz als ganzes
durch andere bands oder durch die fans
anerkannt werden auch das denke ich ist
weder notwendig noch hinreichend ob hier
haben wir das problem der ersten bands
nicht wenn es noch keine band gibt nicht
wie sollen dann bands
entstehen denn es gibt ja keine bands
die die anderen
möchtegern bands dann als solche
anerkennen können und java ruby sondern
freitag könnten auf rügen sonst insel
auch keine band gründen denn es geht
kann jemand anderes recht keine band
keine fans die sie als band anerkennen
können und der das scheint mir kein
plausibles ergebnis zu sein
um jetzt meine eigene eigenen vorschlag
zu entwickeln möchte ich einige
szenarien
diskutieren da hier ein szenario in dem
noch keine band entsteht das musikschul
szenario edm übt in raum 1 1 sondern auf
dem klavier beliebt in raum 2 denselben
song auf dem saxophon sirup den raum 3
auf dem schlagzeugen version sie spielen
völlig synchron
vielleicht zufällig aber vielleicht auch
weil nicht besser auf adam hört ohne
dass er das weiß und es läuft besser
ohne dass sie es weiß ja und es sie sind
halt synchron aber ich denke sie spielen
nicht gemeinsam ja sie
produzieren etwas das für ein zuhörer
sich vielleicht sehr gut anhört aber
es ist kein gemeinsames musizieren gehe
gibt es noch keine band ja szenario 2
der jazzclub
improvisiert auf dem klavier beste stößt
dazu und fängt an dazu auf ihrem saxofon
zu spielen sessel findet ein krümel und
nacht mit ja
hier spielen sie zusammen
sie essen zusammen aber hier denke ich
gibt es auch keine band warum
ja weil kein
keine perspektive da ist noch nicht
zumindest nicht dann über einen längeren
zeitraum hinweg zu existieren ja es gibt
nicht
es gibt einen gemeinsamen musizieren der
gruppe aber nach der einen jam session
gibt es gibt es überhaupt
keinen anlass anzunehmen dass die
nochmal
musizieren ja das sollte bei bands
anders sein und deswegen szenario 3
in der cafeteria der pop akademie
treffen sich einem pc und sessel und sie
finden auch aus dass sie ähnliche
einstellung und sie kamen sichere
instrumente gut ergänzen sie verabreden
sich
für den abend um ein miteinander zu
musizieren
das kommt gut an und sie entscheiden
sich sich regelmäßig zu treffen
mitspielen dann tatsächlich irgendwann
vor publikum die meisten geben sich
einen namen aber ich denke das ist nicht
notwendig das könnte viele namenlose
bands da draußen gegen
gloria sechs theologie von margit
gutterding passt sehr gut auf das
phänomen das ich gerade beschrieben habe
nach der theorie von margit gelbe
bilden sich gruppen dadurch dass
menschen sich
verabreden ja dass sie verabredungen
treffen
personen so sagt gebert können gemeinsam
handeln indem sie ihren individuellen
willen dadurch vereinen dass sie
wechselseitig ihre bereitschaft und
gemeinsam handeln signalisieren die
diese blu rays objekte wie gelbe zement
nicht für diese handlung werden
etabliert durch dieses excel seitige
signalisierten ihre späteren mitglieder
von etablierung spreche ich wenn ich das
gründen den anfang in der zeit meinen
und sie werden konstituiert ja durch die
wechselseitige verpflichtung die joint
commitments sagt gilbert die die
mitglieder wechselseitig haben die durch
dieses wechselseitige signalisieren
entstehen
möchtest du mit mir spazieren gehen ja
ich komme mit ja und dann haben sich
zwei zu einem plural subjekt für einen
spaziergang zusammengefunden und sollte
jetzt einer plötzlich nicht mitgehen
dann hat der andere ja das zeigt die
wechselseitigen verpflichtungen an der
andere das recht da wir sagen der kann
sich zu recht beschweren bei dem anderen
dass er jetzt dieses verpflichtung zum
gemeinsamen spaziergang die eingegangen
ist nicht ein nett ja und wenn wir das
auch bands anwenden
ja man kann auch sagen wenn es werden
etabliert ja sie kommen in die existenz
durch das wechselseitige signalisieren
zwischen ihren mitgliedern dass sie
bereit sind miteinander musik zu machen
im probenkeller oder auf einer bühne
oder im rahmen eines plattenvertrags
nicht da gibt es verschiedene varianten
und
sie werden konstituiert ja wenn sie
einmal
existieren wie
bestehen sie dann weiter fort die zeit
hindurch im durch die wechselseitigen
verpflichtungen ihrer mitglieder die
durch dieses wechselseitige
signalisieren entstehen
ja bereitschaft wozu muss den
signalisiert werden wenn wir eine band
gründen wollen ja in gewissem sinne
natürlich der wille zusammen zu
musizieren aber das wäre noch eine zu
weite beschreibung damit könnten wir
auch ein streichquartett gründen oder
ein symphonieorchester
nicht oder oder eine jamsession
staaten also dass das eine beschreibung
die zu weit ist ja passend wäre
natürlich man sagen wir wollen gemeinsam
eine band bilden heutzutage wäre das
eine mögliche
beschreibung des willens mit dem man
eine band gründen könnte weil wir heute
in unserer popkultur eine vorstellung
davon haben was es heißt eine band zu
haben aber die gab es nicht immer ja das
heißt am anfang der bandgeschichte muss
eine andere beschreibung dieses willens
miteinander zu musizieren
gestanden haben also der wille musste
signalisiert werden in einem bestimmten
stil zu bestimmten gelegenheiten oder in
bestimmten namen zu musizieren
er hat damit können wir also das anfangs
problem der bandgeschichte lösen
ein kontrast bei spielen szenario 4 der
klubmanager gandolfi spürt einen neuen
musik drin sie bittet hätten besser
unter dem namen der ibc geis einige
tracks einzuspielen und jeder von ihnen
unterschreibt mit dorothee einen
entsprechenden vertrag im rahmen der
promotion kampagne organisiert dorf
einige sehr gute gags für singen ja
einigen ist es sehr wichtig das zu sagen
das was hier entsteht das ist keine
richtige band nach das sonst so aussehen
wie eine band aber da hier kommt der
wille zu musizieren nicht aus der gruppe
sondern nach jemand von außen dort sie
bringt die musiker zusammen ja sie gibt
vor wie die drei zu musizieren haben sie
hat die idee
für ein gewinnträchtiges projekts nicht
die musik steht im vordergrund sondern
der kommerzielle erfolg nicht und manche
nehmen dass deswegen lieber ein projekt
ja projekte und bands sind gemeinsam
natürlich
musikgruppen ja wir könnten also
verschiedene musikgruppen
unterscheiden solche gros der wille zum
musizieren von innen heraus entsteht die
richtigen bands ja und da wo er von
außen an die musik heran getragen wird
die projekte fake bands
bei den richtigen bands kann es
natürlich passieren
sie kommen zusammen um musizieren zu
wollen aber nicht der kommerzielle
erfolg stellt sich dann auch ein wie bei
den beatles wie bei erstens wie war
exegese und dann bleibt es nicht aus
natürlich dass verträge abgeschlossen
werden nicht an holen sich die bands ein
manager ja nein es ihn nach der fünfte
beatle sang er hat kein instrument in
der hand gehabt aber trägt natürlich
eher zum erfolg der band auch bei
und durch diese verträge mit dritten
nach science nun
helfer oder sollen science plattenfirmen
science konzertveranstalter werden sich
auch erfolgreiche bands in einen
institutionellen rahmen
eingliedern er hat sie werden verträge
vielleicht auch irgendwann mit einen
anderen machten sie werden vielleicht
verträge abschließen werden entscheiden
darf über den verwendung des namens ja
und so kann es dann eben passieren dass
spätere er später bandmitglieder
früheren bandmitglieder den namens
inhaber des bandnamens
verklagen weil sie in dem projekt der
musikgruppe die unter diesen namen
auftritt doch auch mitspielen wollen
ja das wäre mein vorschlag wenn bands
als anfangs nur als objekte und später
komplexe institutionelle
strukturen
das erfüllt auf jeden fall das kriterium
das benz aus mehreren personen bestehen
dass sie bis zu bestimmten zeiten
gegründet werden ja anders als mengen
die zeitlos existieren werden klug als
subjekte und institutionen
begründet von menschen und es kann ein
flug als subjekt seien für das
musizieren also bands machen musik ist
auch erfüllt sie können diese haben die
diesen willen diese gemeinsame
verpflichtung mit einer bestimmten
instrumentierung haben die spezifische
arbeitsteilung wird es damit eingefangen
aufgrund der ford existierenden
wechselseitigen verpflichtungen können
bands durch die zeit hindurch existieren
per sistieren die metaphysiker so gerne
sagen
bands können zu verschiedenen leuten aus
verschiedenen personen bestehen in dem
gewisse mitglieder
aus den gemeinsamen verpflichtungen
entlassen werden von den anderen
bandmitgliedern möchten den man sich
einig dass man eben mit dieser
konstellation nicht mehr zusammenspielen
möchte aber andere können aufgenommen
werden in das blu-ray subjekts noch in
dem alle ihren willen signalisieren in
zukunft mit diesem neuen mitglied
gemeinsam musizieren zu wollen können
bands lücken in ihrer existenz haben ja
da würde ich gerne eine differenzierte
antwort geben
wenn die mitglieder einer bands band
eben gesagt hatte wir wären jetzt auf
mich wie eben unsere verpflichtungen im
einvernehmen wechsel ein einvernehmen
wir unsere verpflichtungen nehmen wir
unsere verpflichtungen auf miteinander
musik zu zum musizieren dann hört die
band auf zu existieren dann wird in
florenz objekt auf zu existieren
wir können natürlich später dieselben
personen sagen lasst uns doch wieder
anknüpfen an unsere glorreiche
vergangenheit und noch einmal auftreten
vielleicht sogar in rollo gramm form und
hc dass das ist eine frage die ich jetzt
noch nicht integriert habe
aber das wäre erst einmal ein neues
plural subjekt ein neues commitment das
sie eingehen ja also 1 1 neue soziale
entität aber sie könnten natürlich den
bilden signalisieren an
ihre vorgeschichte anzuknüpfen er hat
sie könnten sagen wir wollen eben mit
diesen neuen blog als subjekt fortsetzen
was wir damals aufgegeben haben das
könnte so lange erfolgreich den anspruch
auf identität
aufrechterhalten solange es keine
konkurrenz gibt ich bin
zwei beatles jeweils
nicht den den anspruch gehabt hätten
jetzt
gründen wie die
beatles band wieder neu
nicht beide können nicht mit dem
vorgänger identisch sein
das spricht dafür dass wir es damit doch
eher mit dem phänomen des eines
nachfolgers zu tun haben als mit dem
phänomen der identität ja so war es ein
überblick
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit ich
bin sicher es gibt einige fragen